it's going live you see
it says live here hey here we are okay
surprise [ __ ]
yeah we actually we're not gonna live
stream today
uh because it's friday and i already put
up the bubba hotep review earlier
but i went out and got a new laptop
yesterday just like i said i was going
to
and we wanted to see if it was going to
work
uh you know in response to like i don't
see any lag
look how good i mean yeah see
we got it i actually like had i
brought i bought a brand new it wasn't
like a super expensive laptop or
anything but it's like
i don't i have two other computers i
have a pc
and a mac so this one is just going to
be like the dedicated
streaming laptop yeah we got two people
in right now just jumped in
i guess how does it look guys does it
look better than it did before
i mean for us it looks better and it's
not lagging so thank [ __ ] god
now we still haven't got the um the what
you call it the
ethernet cable which i think is going to
come today but it looks like i mean i
might still use it
but if it's going to work without that
then then that would be
good too or come on said yeah yeah yeah
look great yeah oh good yay so
so it wasn't a few hundred dollars like
wasted yeah
and we didn't have the ethernet cable do
we no it's supposed to come today but i
guess it hasn't arrived yet i haven't
got a notification
that might improve it even more it may
yeah because like i said that's
they they really don't suggest that um
they really don't suggest that you use
wi-fi to live stream
yeah so so i'm hoping that i bought a
50-foot ethernet cable for 18
and it's supposed to come today yeah i
didn't i was moving stuff around because
i bought this laptop yesterday and i put
it like i already had i had the mac one
which i had to move over to that side
but they were next to each other for a
little while so this one was over here
on the corner of the desk and of course
the first thing that i did like i
you know i had it open i had it set up
and it was sitting there open on the
corner the first thing that pookie did
was jump up right onto the keyboard
plonk
see where this see what this uh laptop
is yeah i like that
i'm gonna like that there's something
there i'm gonna put that on air thing
there
oh you're gonna oh did you order that no
but we're gonna order maybe it'll be up
where
maybe it'll be up there in the uh up in
the corner where that little turmeric
bag is
yeah maybe like back there okay where
that blue light i have to put those
turmeric bags like in the
tea cabinet that way the show's a little
more visual
yeah he wants to get he wants to get it
sorry this just came
i want to get one of these one of those
signs like they're wrong like they have
like another podcaster says it says
on air so we can look all the way like
i'm professional yeah
and that shit's [ __ ] hooks up on
bluetooth so i could grab my thing here
and then just press it
and turn it off across there's some
space age [ __ ] so [ __ ] all the aliens
have when i was a kid
on air hold on where's my death ray god
damn it
but yeah so uh so hopefully i mean it
does seem like and to me the picture
looks sharper
another thing that uh that i didn't
realize was gonna be good too was that
when i hooked up the pc to our webcam
um it downloaded the um the software for
that particular webcam
which it didn't do on the mac because i
guess it didn't have any mac compatible
uh software it still worked like through
quicktime and stuff but
it didn't um it wasn't like maximized i
suppose
so because i've done like records so the
recorded shits should
probably work better like you look
better as well and our voices are in
sync with our mouths now too
i know isn't that nice now i can
actually like look at myself on the
screen without like getting all [ __ ]
confused
because i'm like [ __ ] running yeah
there's only like a 375
laptop we're just going to use it just
for [ __ ] streaming yeah i'm not cuz
like i said i have two other ones i have
you know the pc that i use for video
editing i have the mac that i use for
graphic design
um and so this is just going to be like
the dedicated streaming computer like i
said i will probably also hook up the
ethernet cable to it as well just
to be on the safe side yeah as soon as
we get it
it'll probably get clearer if we got i
mean the bad thing is though now that
we're
in hd now you can see like all our
wrinkles and [ __ ] like that you can see
that anyway
[Laughter]
i don't have that many girls
i'm getting up there in age i know we
are well it's like you know what are you
gonna do about it
still it's gonna look great in here man
you know the uh the lighting
is more effective so yeah i could put a
better backdrop back here now
yeah we can do all kinds of fun things
it's gonna look a lot better
you're never to go out in the sun what
wrinkles
i only go out in the sun very early in
the morning when i go for my walk i
don't i try not to like lay out in it
too much
but yeah um so i did a computer yeah
everybody's gonna buy a new computer
yeah we just got it yesterday like this
is my third one so it's going to look
like
it looks all like [ __ ] high attack in
here i look like a hacker like
from one of those from one of those
cheesy ass like 90s movies
i'm gonna be sitting there going like
that with like [ __ ] scrolling in the
thing on the background
that's what i should put back there all
this scrolling kind of [ __ ] so you all
think i'm like some big hacker or
something
yeah but yeah we did we were just doing
a test today we didn't have any
movies to review particularly or
anything like that
so we just wanted to see if it was
probably uh handle some of those moving
lights that i have
maybe whoa look like a [ __ ] disco up
in this [ __ ]
yeah you need to have scrolling stuff
projecting under your face yeah yeah
i know we're just gonna like do this all
the stupidest [ __ ] we could possibly
imagine
we're gonna have a disco ball like a
[ __ ] lookout
have some of our friends come over here
and dance and go in the background
girls on poles strippers strippers that
we know
that would be fun yeah have kaylee back
there with kitty or something
[Laughter]
yeah so uh what else uh was i gonna say
oh remember because i said that i was
gonna start doing
uh book reviews i decided i was gonna
wait until halloween but [ __ ] it um i
already have two of them done
and i already have most of a third book
finished um
you know to read so i can review it so i
think what i'm going to do is start
putting them up
at the end of august or the beginning of
september i think i'm going to put them
up on mondays
you know what i mean just because it
feels like we do the show on saturday
night and then we just kind of do
some live show month and so i'll have
something to put up on monday
zach's asking if i saw that finished
dominatrix
thing no zach i don't have time to see
all that dude i'm being
bombarded i mean we got people sending
us blu-rays that we haven't even seen
yet i got
20 blu-ray movies i gotta watch yeah we
have a pile it's like
it's right next to the tv which we're
slowly
pookie likes very much because then when
she wants our attention she can just
jump up there and just
push the [ __ ] over be like
hey are you guys gonna like let me go
outside or feed me or whatever it is
that you want to do
she's hilarious yep um do you have
anything else you'd like to talk about
no but i am glad that uh this worked out
yeah me too it looks good pookie the
all-powerful
oh can we talk about for a second we
have been watching on 2b
we have been watching or like catching
up on some of the old seasons of
hoarders
oh god man because we had seen the new
season which i think was on netflix or
whatever the [ __ ] it was on
but when we looked at 2b they had season
6 7 8
9 and 10 and maybe 11. i didn't even
realize
one that had been on that long and i
didn't i thought we'd seen them all but
we watched like all of season six or a
lot of season six and i haven't seen any
of those
so um you know the episode i can't
remember what season it was
with that woman that was like the bag
shedder she was sitting in bags and
storing them yeah and [ __ ] up
in the top bathroom and the floor caved
in
the floor they had to contend the whole
house yeah remember that one
okay well we thought that was the worst
one nope no there was a word there's a
worse one than that
nope they had this girl i was calling
her moonpie
she looked like a 3d living version of a
south park
[ __ ] character she did now that she
mentioned it i feel kind of bad because
she's mentally she had a totally round
head with these [ __ ]
sharp ass [ __ ] teeth coming out
sideways
and she was pissing and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] big old [ __ ] juice
half gallon juice yeah those plastic
juice bags and juice bottles
and that was all over the [ __ ] house
just piled up and then it was all piled
up out in the backyard
and then when that when she ran out of
juice bottles of ju once juice bottles
took over
she was then pissing and [ __ ] in a
bucket and pouring that
into a pan and walking it out over a
mountain of garbage in the damn house to
be sloshing out all over
and she'd throw it out and they had the
[ __ ] health inspectors come over and
she's like do you smell something in
here
they're like yeah like because they say
it smells kind of musty i think the mold
happened she kept saying musty
musty it's like mold and they're like no
it smells like piss and [ __ ]
they're like your house is full of [ __ ]
but no
total [ __ ] denial she's like i can't
smell that but i do smell a little bit
of mold smelling in there
like this was [ __ ] crazy it was and
this is yeah it goes to show you
there's got to be limits to people's
freedoms
you can't just be free to [ __ ] in these
bottles and stack them up beside your
damn house
like i said that is something that who
would think of that
not me that's for sure apparently i'm
not all that
this is what happens when you click when
you close down all those loony bins they
have to bring these looney bins back
because this [ __ ] here she couldn't live
on her own
i mean they have ones like that but
they're really expensive and if you
don't have insurance you're kind of
[ __ ] no they need to have some
state-run loony bins for people who just
can't live on their own
she could probably live in a group home
something like that i think they were
even kind of talking i don't think they
like to say like unless the person's
like
really old um or and have like you know
physical issues as well
i don't think they usually like to say
anything about putting them
somewhere like in a home right yeah um
this woman was young
i mean she was only she looked like she
was maybe only in her 30s
yeah i mean if that it was taking its
toll on her though i mean
yeah but she didn't strike me she wasn't
very old and they did say something
about
her not being able to live by her oh
thank you very much j
couch thank you very much bro chipping
in on a [ __ ] computer
thank you very much thank you very much
that was elvis that was stepping in
thank you very much yeah that goes with
the whole theme today because we
reviewed bubba hotels
it was a good review but it was i well
we both love that movie so it's like
really and it's like fun to talk about
because like the premise of it is so
crazy
but yeah so this woman so they did like
say something about
you know maybe putting her somewhere i
don't know if they meant like putting
her in an institution
or putting her like making her stay with
relatives because i would think that if
all of her relatives would be like yeah
no
yeah we don't want her because she'll be
like [ __ ] all over
because that's the thing it's like i
know they can't help it i know it's a
mental illness
but it's like that's what happens like
when you let a hoarder
like when they [ __ ] up their house and
then they go to the whole neighborhood
and then they move in with like a
relative and then they [ __ ] up the
relatives house too they start like
putting [ __ ] in their house yeah
and it's like the whole some of them
were [ __ ] up the whole neighborhood
well yeah
you could smell it [ __ ] blocks away
rats
disease you know it's a damn health
hazard plague that's how [ __ ] starts
that's what i mean it's like you know
you're just like [ __ ] up the whole
neighborhood there's gonna be roaches in
like the neighbor's house the whole
neighborhood's gonna smell
[ __ ] bag lady [ __ ] bag lady they met
when they tore her whole house down
they did yeah i think they ended up i
told them to pull her house down and she
didn't want to go to any home or she'd
want to do this so they just said okay
[ __ ] off [ __ ] out of here and she just
walked off walked off into the sunset
yeah that's the genesis of a bomb that's
where bombs come from they just walk off
but she wouldn't even be allowed in a
bomb camp
well that's what i mean it's like the
[ __ ] where she's well and some of the
people it's like it's really sad because
i mean some of the people that are in
there it's like homeless people
live better because it's like at least
they're not sleeping in a house like all
in their own filth and like just letting
rats and roaches and [ __ ] crawl all over
them i would rather sleep outside
thank you melanie you were awesome oh my
gosh we just like came on surprisingly
just to say hey look we got a new thing
and it's not lagging anymore
so everyone's very happy about it i'm
very happy about it yeah because i was
getting sick of that [ __ ] lagging
[ __ ] too yeah i was getting sick of that
[ __ ] fuzzy
ill-defined low resolution look
and how everything was out of [ __ ]
sync you know what i mean it's like
i'm being all animated and i look
[ __ ] insane man because
my [ __ ] words aren't lining up in my
mouth
it looks crazy well especially the more
you drink like the more you move around
like your little butt starts swiveling
like all over the chairs yeah we start
like
what the [ __ ] does that dude do
which is really funny so if people don't
hear like the explanation of being being
like yeah it's lagging again and then
they get to the end and then you're just
like going
yeah like all over the [ __ ]
look at like max headroom or something
yeah right exactly
tonight is friday isn't it it is oh [ __ ]
man what does that mean
because i got all that [ __ ] tequila
and i got all that rock star
sitting up in there man we ought to do a
stream tonight in just a drunk stream
because we got a stream we're gonna do
the show tomorrow yeah we're gonna
stream we're gonna stream the show
tomorrow night and
the no they were doing a really [ __ ]
up topic too no no nightclubs or
anything you know
nope can't go out so i was like i don't
know maybe we ought to just get drunk on
stream
i don't know i had a couple movies i
needed to watch today you tired
she's tired i'm always tired if you know
what if i didn't do [ __ ] when i was
tired then i would never do [ __ ]
probably make more money on a drunk
stream than we would on a [ __ ] show
stream
although i mean the regular show stream
is the tech is a drunk stream
well yeah i mean usually you get drunk
quicker than me because i usually have
to like
follow the notes and stuff yeah i
usually drink slower
there's some behind-the-scenes
information for y'all
you're not gonna say anything bad about
me no no okay
i make her drinks about half of what i
make mine yeah because she's got to be
able to read
i have to be able to read and like keep
track of like notes and have
somewhat of a coherent yeah i'm just
just trying to be the comedic relief you
know what i mean i'm the substitute
audience i'm just trying to like no way
just reacting to [ __ ] and
it's hard to do like damn damn it's hard
to do a solo show
it is i've done it and it's like it is
hard you gotta have somebody standing
next to you to [ __ ] kind of react and
play off of if
it's just you and then the audience just
feels a lot harder yeah
it's a lot harder i mean i found i it's
not as bad as it used to like because
i've done like a
recorded a couple book reviews and i
think they came out good i didn't like
[ __ ] them up too many times
um because you know yeah it's just a
show
it's harder to do a live show i think by
yourself
it is yeah yeah i think so yeah i mean
did i do a couple i think i did a couple
because you weren't
around yeah and yeah i always just kind
of feel like i'm
he's like i'm just gonna wander off over
here and yeah
do something oh but yeah one one thing i
wanted to say about like the
moon pie [ __ ] lady that was on the
tv it's just like i had had like i think
i only had like one drink last night but
it was kind of strong
so like by the time that had rolled
around because you guys like i can watch
gore all day long but um
i can't watch anything poop related
without wanting to heave
you got to get it you got to try to get
like a photograph from the show of
moonpie's head
just moonpie's face and make that lady
make that a meme on the show something
gets real [ __ ] nasty talk about [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just pop [ __ ] move with
the little bottles in the corner
well actually the photo that that they
used
for her for the for the uh for the
[ __ ] thumbnail for that particular
yeah i was like oh that poor lady as
soon as i saw that woman i was like man
it looks that woman looks like
something off of south park yeah she
started calling her boom
no her head looks like a [ __ ] and
then i felt really bad for her but then
like when we saw the actual show i'm
like oh [ __ ] i guess there's not really
a flattering picture you could take a
compass and put it right in the center
of the [ __ ] picture of the nose
and draw a perfect circle and it would
match her head perfectly
and it was yellow like a [ __ ] moon
pie like a round [ __ ] move
like a nano teeth a nano moon
from alabama i can't stand that i love
bananas
other other moon pies are all right but
i can't stand fake banana flavored
anything i'm not even really a big fan
of real bananas
i'll eat them if i have to but i really
don't like that one
when i was a kid i went through i went
[ __ ] i really [ __ ]
jumped the shark when it comes nana
moonpies
[Laughter]
[ __ ] this should be i don't think i've
heard this story yeah well zach i was at
grandma's house
that's that's where all the most [ __ ]
started she had
man and moon pies and chocolate mopass
okay
and oreos all right i was eating oreos
and i was looking to eat bananas
moon pies and chocolate moon pies you're
eating all that i just started to think
what would it be like if if a banana
moon pie was like a oreo
so i opened up two chocolate moo pies
and a banana moon pies and put put the
banana
pie in between the
[Laughter]
big man it was like [ __ ] bigger than
a big mac
it's like a baconator except i ate that
god that [ __ ] was so sweet even as a
little kid i couldn't get through it
wow that's saying something
why did i do this
you gave it a valiant effort though yeah
yeah i don't remember ever doing
anything i mean
the weirdest [ __ ] i did was because you
know i love little debbies
like some of them some of them are gross
but um like the nana ones
but they you know you'd always take like
the swiss cake rolls and you'd like
unroll them
and then like eat the unrolled one and
sometimes i would take the zebra cakes
and like pull them in half and then you
could put another one like an oatmeal
oatmeal pie in the bed yeah that'd like
make a little sandwich they're saying
that ought to be one for the cookbook
that's actually some [ __ ] that elvis
would have tried to eat
i mean we've all been there okay it's
like you know sometime when you're a kid
or when you're like drunk or even
you know maybe smoking a little
something i just want to try to eat that
[ __ ] back in the vegas phase
yeah you just see it
[Laughter]
how is the cookbook coming by the way
well like i said i have
i have like the pages like templated out
yeah and what's gonna
what each recipe is gonna be
we're gonna uh we have to see she's got
other projects she's yesterday i know
i'm trying to finish it
structures yeah yeah because i have like
all the pages laid out because i have
there's going to be like different
variations of pages just like i did with
the
um with the uh vegan black metal chef's
book
there was like you know six different
page designs and you could just like
kind of
you know so i did like a whole bunch of
different page designs and then now we
could just like slap in like the photos
and it all be written in my voice that's
what i'm saying
i think that would be like really really
funny
like it just i mean i've i know you so
well like i've known you so long that i
could probably just like
write it just write it on her own with
my own because just like listening to
like imagining how you would say it
yeah so the mexican section is going to
be really good because it's going to
have
my step-by-step instruction experience
on making tortillas themselves
and getting that damn press yeah because
he just got that pressed yeah i just got
that press in and that i got this cast
iron pressed from mexico
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] that high high
speed and my uh my buddy jair down in
[ __ ] tijuana you know he
[ __ ] go live with him and uh
he's kind of walking me through it it
takes there's trial and error on how to
make a
a a tortilla got to be the right size
about the size of a ping-pong ball and
you need two pieces of plastic
because i tried wax paper it sticks but
if you have plastic above it and below
it
you can squeeze it in that press if you
squeeze it part of the way you can
open it back up make any adjustments
that way it's dead in the center
because it's hard to judge yeah during
the squishing process
and if you over squish it'll get too
thin
and then when you try to make the taco
to fall apart
it's got to be the right thickness you
have to get the feel of how much to
squeeze it
and you don't want to cook it in a in a
pan that has any oil in it it's got to
just be a non-stick
or a cast a real well you know uh
seasoned cast iron pad and it comes out
it'll come out like
when your little corn tortilla shells
that you'd buy at the store they come
out like that you can store them and
eat them in the you know put them in the
um uh
refrigerator you know in a zip lock
you've been doing that too but then you
fry it back up in oil
they're good they don't taste anything
like a store-bought tortilla it's just
nice they're way way better yeah
i mean the flavor is way better because
you made chicken tacos with them last
night
yeah and they were really really good
yeah it's more like cornbread
yeah it tastes more like real good
southern cornbread
and it's pretty cheap you know that
maseca i think it's about four or five
bucks for a big old bag of it that makes
a pretty good amount of
tortillas and they're just fresh and
just nothing can nothing can compete
with it
yeah i mean everything's better if you
make it yeah and then like uh
i experimented i overcooked some of them
to turn them into
corn chips and man yeah those are gonna
take some
nachos with these things jesus christ we
should do that sometime this
weekend yeah i can make some badass
nachos with that
see what everybody's saying the
squishing process
i'm increasing their blood pressure by
talking about [ __ ] all the sugars
well you know we always we always kind
of get talking about little debbies for
some reason
it's just the south it is yeah and you
know when i was a kid my grandma [ __ ]
loved those
nostalgia she always had like tons of
boxes of them because they were super
cheap you know
they had these they had these boxes they
had a whole these little debbies they
came in a big old [ __ ] flat box
and they were oatmeal cookie sandwiches
that had a [ __ ] marshmallow in the
middle of them remember those
oh yeah and they were all individually
wrapped
if you ate them on their own they
weren't all that special but if you
just opened that wrapper and microwaved
them for 15 seconds they came
man they were [ __ ] good yeah some of
them were really good when they were hot
you really either had the microwave or
some of them were better if you froze
them
probably enough yeah just like candy
bars some of them are better frozen
remember the little cinnamon swirls the
little they're like little
cinnamon rolls yeah they had those too
right those were good heating well yeah
you have to eat those those are really i
mean eating like a cinnamon roll at
room temperature is just sad don't do
that like heat it up for like five
seconds in the microwave and it's like
all gooey and squishy
yeah it'd be like you know they'd sell
us big boxes of them for a dollar
yeah they were a 99 99 cents for a huge
box i think there was eight or twelve of
them in there depending on what kind it
was because some of them were bigger
than that and it was just a southern
product and
that's why a lot of southerners were fat
man they were [ __ ] eating those
things not just that
remember the nutter butter bars the
nutter bars and that was it isn't that
what it was called
yeah what are we called [ __ ] man it's
like a [ __ ] gigantic
wafer peanut butter yeah wait for dick
dipped in chocolate [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and chopped
damn there'd be something to get [ __ ]
in chocolate wasn't it
that's a little bit of a [ __ ] it might
happen in prison
oh my goodness and then that just made
me think of letting people like
like sticking the nutter butter away for
things of people's butt and stuff it's
like
why why did we go there i don't know
nutty bars that's what they're called
yeah nutty bars yeah those are pretty
good bars
yeah nutty bars like i said we should we
should do like a whole show on like
ranking
little tabbies like which ones are good
which ones are
i don't know what's asking if we can set
it up so we can play the intro
and outro during the live streams do you
have to do that um i don't know i could
figure it out probably
yeah yeah i think i was wondering about
that because i thought people would
probably miss like the intro and the
outro like the credits and then like um
the videos of pokey that i used to put
in the middle um
i mean i guess i could take videos of
cookie and then just like put them up
separately
this is going to be a dedicated
streaming identification
identification it's going to be a
dedicated streaming
computer so you might be able to hook
that up yeah i'll have to figure out how
to do that you're making me laugh so
much of my eyes making her do too much
work zach
but it's right we probably should have
that we probably shouldn't
it's almost time for a new one for a new
it was an intro and outro
yeah it could probably just be shorter
i mean the one we had was only like five
seconds i think okay well i don't
remember is it five seconds i can't
remember
it's because like i said the last few
shows we haven't used it
because a lot of that [ __ ] is that okay
[Laughter]
a lot of stuff is is reaching expiration
date though we just need to replace it
with newer stuff
freshen it up just if you ask me
because we've been using that we've been
using that
intro and outro for a couple years now
since yeah
2018 i think yeah i mean it's not time
to get a newer one
maybe something uh i know you come up
with something
eventually yeah eventually i'll come up
with something
i'm trying to finish that uh my
presentation for the strange realities
conference
yeah well you know when you get ready i
almost i i got the
the written part done i just have to
make like the little powerpoint
presentation
okay like this afternoon so that's what
i'm gonna work on but like i said this
was just kind of like a little surprise
i didn't even announce this last room i
don't think um you know
just so we could see if it was working
it looks like it's
working delightfully i mean yeah like i
said maybe the ethernet cable might even
make it even like better
but it's like look we look like all
right we look all crisp and lovely and
you know our mouths and our choices are
it's better than it was
it's not totally perfect but it's it's
better than it was well nothing's
totally perfect
yeah you know all right it's better than
it was so
i guess we'll yeah we'll see you guys
tomorrow yeah
tomorrow night uh 5 p.m eastern standard
time
they say the sound is amazing really
yeah the
same mic it's the same microphone but oh
no no no that's mango saying that
telling beth the old ones that something
sounds amazing oh okay
yeah cold milk so she's talking about
cold milk with them damn nutty but nutty
bars oh yeah
man i i still i used to love that like
cause i can't really drink like whole
milk anymore because
i'll be gigantic but um i used to like
iced whole milk
germans kind of make that those kind of
wafer candies you know and
they do like really good jobs like what
was that kind that we had a little
square what's your favorite
yeah what the hell are those kind of
hazelnuts yeah
yeah those are delicious all right
they're extremely high quality
that's not how you're gonna do it in the
south all right you're gonna make it a
high quantity
[Laughter]
imagine you took that [ __ ] bar and
you took it to willy wonka and you put
it in that tv machine to make everything
bigger
all right he was actually making [ __ ]
smaller right it
seems like it's bigger but it's the
quality
suffers yeah you know uh so the nutter
bars were big man i remember them being
about six
seven inches long thank you very much
man they're like six or seven inches
long and they were
tall maybe like an inch tall but they
were kind of coarse
and they were filled with you know what
i mean like the yeah
and the chocolate was very waxy and it's
thin the chocolate
was kind of thin on that yeah it was a
coating of chocolate very thin and the
wafer itself was kind of coarse
and the filling was it tasted like
peanut butter but it was kind of like
cheap real sugary sweet
peanut butter a peanut butter adjacent
person like a peter
a peanut butter like substance that's
it's like peanut powder
or something yeah it might have been
mixed yeah it's weird it might have been
like
they tasted good until you got to the
very end of them
you were sick of it and that's not the
way
i'm talking about they're like oh these
are pretty good and then all of a sudden
you start getting the last few bites
here like it was like
chore you're like okay it's done it's
over
and that's that was an ordeal yeah
that's not the way the german ones were
those german ones you could sit in bed
probably eat a second case of them
no they were addicted to taste i
probably could but well
debbie was just about giving you
something that was really big really
sweet
really cheap yeah yeah and american
chocolate is notoriously not that good
um european chocolate depending on the
company that you're talking about
hershey's
i mean hershey is kind of like the the
main selling one in a lot of people
like europeans think that hershey's
chocolate tastes like
vomit which it kind of does a little bit
because it has
a little bit of a curdled milk kind of
thing that they don't do over there
um so the chocolate in europe i will
agree is like tastes a lot better except
for like ones over here like ghirardelli
and stuff those are good
but hershey's isn't that i'll eat it but
it's not fantastic yeah
the thing is is that the hershey's
company kind of had a very unique
place in history it's been american
history
and that that appeared in the 1800s in a
time when chocolate was just not
affordable
yeah you know poor people would not
could never afford it yeah that was all
fancy people
that's fancy [ __ ] they were able to take
a small amount of cocoa beans and make a
piece of chocolate that a child could
buy for a penny
and that was just unheard of yeah uh it
you're not talking gourmet [ __ ] this is
something you sold to the people
the united states was always about
trying to had a big demand and they were
trying to
make the supply meet that demand and it
had it was low-income people so it was
almost a soviet-style
mass production cape you know a problem
to to to to feed america so the first
things that appeared on a natural
on a national level were big cheap
were big production cheap low quality
products
they were trying to democratize food or
democratize
wealth and give it to the people it was
just another time and hershey's was one
of those cubs
heinz was another one heinz sold
pickled stuff uh when you look at
ketchup mustard and relish and pickled
stuff you know pickles you see those as
condiments
but in the 1800s those were those those
were whole food products
that was the only vegetable you were
gonna get gonna have a big old bowl of
ketchup well they put it on meat
yeah and they were uh they're putting it
on meat and that was a substitute for a
vegetable because there was no
refrigeration
yeah and you could keep that on a shelf
in indefinitely and you know you we
wonder why
they looked as funny as they did and why
they were so skinny and scrawny and
unhealthy-looking because what they were
eating it was [ __ ]
yeah you know canned meat half that damn
[ __ ] food was coming off of [ __ ]
rotten cows a lot of it came off of
rotten cows
which what was that called concrete
jungle that [ __ ] book that exposed
all that
of the meat packing it was just called
the jungle the jungle sinclair lewis
yeah yeah we read it in school
yeah i had to read that like in fifth
grade i think fourth the fifth grade at
the fifth or sixth yeah i remember
school yeah something like that i think
it was fifth and man it just exposed how
bad you know the early industries were
you know especially the meat packing
industry
it's a totally they just taken they
they find a damn half a rotten cow that
was got
fallen behind a big thing and they'd say
oh we gotta make we gotta keep
fell behind the desk behind the thing
it's been back there a couple extra days
you know
this this it's only going to be you know
it's going to go in this gigantic vat
what do we do i don't waste it
and they'd pour holes in it and pour lie
in it and
try to get the stink out of it and try
to sanitize a big old
half of that rotten cow and then they
throw that in the [ __ ]
big old pot of boiling water along with
all the good cows and then just run it
through a centrifuge and [ __ ]
pack it and pack it in cans and send it
out to people
yeah food was scary before they actually
had any like standards
or laws or anything yeah saying that you
had to have things be a particular
there's like whatever just throw it all
in there it'll be
probably not many people will die yeah
well
i really think a lot of it was ignorance
uh some of it was sure
a lot of jesus didn't know well you know
if it smells okay it's okay
you know if we cook it and it'll it'll
kill everything and it's
gonna only be one part per two thousand
once it's diluted
with all the rest of these cows it'll be
all right they're not really thinking
about
cross contamination and you know
spreading of [ __ ] bacteria although i
think
most of the bacteria have been killed in
the cooking process
but it's just gross yeah they didn't
think that way nope
they think that way yeah this is 1800s
you know [ __ ] nasty [ __ ]
yeah they're nasty [ __ ] were they as
nasty as a
moonpie [ __ ] lady no they weren't that
nasty they would have known better
yeah but they were nastier they still
kept lots of [ __ ] in the house though
it's called a [ __ ] chamber pot
well yeah piss and [ __ ] in the pot and
just put it in the damn [ __ ]
tuck it back under the bed and then
sleep on it yeah they're [ __ ] crazy
you know so they were tolerant of
[ __ ] nastiness
i don't i don't understand how i mean
upbringing i just i just like you know
what i take out the garbage i just touch
the top of the garbage
can and i'm like i okay i have to wash
my hands
no i'm like not ocd or anything nothing
today is people are spoiled man they're
out there [ __ ] crying and
over [ __ ] poisonous environments
and [ __ ] how bad the environment they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about
1800 city life was toxic as [ __ ]
as [ __ ] uh there was no controls over
any of these leather
industries and those things were [ __ ]
filthy
uh they were using mercury in most of
their processes yeah
and mercury was in all the [ __ ]
drinking water the ground water it was
all in your canned food because
there was mercury in the solders that
they used to close everything so they
were
they were [ __ ] up they were mostly
poisoned there was lots and lots of
birth defects and they didn't know why
uh rampant [ __ ] [ __ ] like syphilis
that would make somebody look like eddie
from iron maiden and they got photos of
it it's [ __ ] horrible
what what a child born from a syphilitic
mother looked like once that syphilis
was on that fetus and it came out grew
it looked just like eddie from iron
maiden
yeah they had him like that was walking
around in the institutions
it was horrible um
which that gave rise to a lot of the
[ __ ]
weird concepts like you know karl marx
and everything of his complaints
he was complaining about a world that no
longer exists it was much worse than
today much worse
and a lot more violent and also
we could talk about how violent
today is and there's nothing compared to
the 70s 70s was very violent
uh but they say in the early 1800s in
american cities and even in european
cities like places up in
up in up in um uh scotland and wales
some of those cities were [ __ ]
horribly violent where murder was just
common
yeah oh well and everyone just got away
with it because they didn't have like
any forensic science to speak of so it's
like unless somebody saw somebody
butchering somebody in the street that
they didn't catch you
yeah doing it you you know you kind of
just could do it murder
rape cannibalism thank you mango bags uh
enslaving of women
uh with common sexual slavery was pretty
[ __ ] common they did all kinds of
[ __ ] that
you wouldn't think of now we're not
talking about black slavery we're
talking about white slavers you know
white women were being enslaved as sex
slaves in
prostitution rings it was uh and a lot
of the thought time this wasn't [ __ ]
spoken about
and then they were killing people to
sell the cadavers to adopt to doctors
yeah it was just
it was a lot worse back then
and if [ __ ] we don't play our cards
right it'll just go back to that that's
actually the normal state
of mankind uh if you read the right
authors
uh there was a good russian author that
talked about it his name is dmitry
orkolov
and he goes through all the stages of
societal collapsed because uh
he survived the collapse of the soviet
union and he was
got way into history and wrote about his
experiences during the soviet collapse
and he says if you go back to history
actually
most of mankind is in a stage of what's
called stage three collapse
thank you tony thank you very much
stage three collapse is the normal state
of mankind
and it's bad you know we're actually in
one of the good
parts of of history and there's
collapses going back
for probably the oldest one that we know
about was the
collapse of the bronze age there's a
bunch of bronze age
civilizations that collapsed because of
a group called the sea
people sea people came and then you know
sea people came and invaded and [ __ ]
destroyed all the cities and this and
that and when you look at
egyptian carvings of who the sea people
were
and the names that were given when you
saw them it was just
families in carts being pulled by oxen
with warriors
so you're talking about a mass migration
is what they're talking about
and the cities that they're talking
about or the lands where
they came from sound like italy sounds
like
sicily and places from the greco-roman
park which
you know the italians really didn't have
much knowledge of that area
but they went into uh but you know i'm
getting ahead of myself we're supposed
to be shutting this [ __ ] down anyway
yeah that was like 15 minutes ago
all right people look my glass
is empty this wasn't and i swear this is
not an alcoholic drink it's only like
three in the afternoon
or three thirty in the afternoon this
was water with like some
mango [ __ ] in it yeah but uh i i
encourage you guys to
surprise some stuff on youtube about uh
the bronze age collapse
and and the sea people that's a that's a
good uh a lot of historians talk about
that very interesting story
yeah yeah all right so you want to wrap
it up that's it
all right i gotta start working on this
presentation again too because i really
want to get this damn thing done today
all right all right so we'll see you
guys uh tomorrow night for the regular
show
everybody get your cocktails prepared
because it's gonna
it's gonna be good yeah it's gonna be a
real unpleasant topic i'm just gonna say
but fun in its own way and in a messed
up kind of way so we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow and uh thanks for
dropping by this little surprise live
stream that we have
bye no
okay okay come on
you're still running oh yeah you sure
you want to enter the stream yes
in the street